alright ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to introduction to es6 and you know we
might want to actually call this es6
plus because i'm gonna throw in some es
7 + es 8 features that I think are pop
that are good and exciting and that you
should know as a JavaScript developer if
you're a little unfamiliar with how
JavaScript gets new additions to its
programming language the Ekman script
foundation who runs JavaScript at the
end of the day every year they do an
update and they release new content es6
was 2015 es 7 2016 yes 8 2017 and so
we're gonna be talking about some of the
latest additions to the language in over
17 lessons and four challenges I will be
your host if you will for this course my
name is Dylan Israel I am my content
creator on YouTube I also have udemy
courses scrubber courses I'm also a
full-time front-end engineer you click
this icon you can go find some of my
videos and check it out but let's go
ahead and dive into all the fun
strings historically in JavaScript have
been sort of a second-class citizen and
haven't got as much love as other
programming languages might have in the
past so what we're gonna be talking
about right now is template literals and
what that's going to allow us to do is
going to first I guess first let's go
ahead and showcase how what the issue
might have been with strings in the past
let's say we had a word one and we said
that's equal to Dylan and we had word
let were two equal to my last name of
Israel so if we wanted to concatenate
this in the past and some sort of
constant if we wanted doesn't really
matter and we'll say full name well I
could kinda need this in the past we
would have to do something like word 1
plus and then because we want it to look
nice empty character plus word 2 and
then we could of course console dot log
out word full name just me and you'll
see here that we get this you know it's
nice this isn't the prettiest way and it
gets very it gets very long very ugly
very quickly right this is a pretty
basic example so template literals
allow us to using backticks let's go
ahead and delete this using backticks
which if you're not if you can't find
back pics on the keyboard I didn't know
where they existed there to the left of
the one key on on a keyboard we can use
this dollar sign opening curly brace
closing curly brace pass in our value
here put a space go ahead and pass in
our value to here and you'll see when we
save now we're able to print it out and
we can do this much easily or easier
rather than having to repeat ourselves
with pluses and spaces but that's not it
there's a lot more that we can do with
template literals as well template
literals also give us an easy way of
having variables say we wanted to have
you know let num1 equal to 2 and let
num2 equal to 3 and we didn't know what
they were gonna be we actually just have
is this at the end it's just JavaScript
we have no 1 plus num2 and we can do
the sort of catenation of our variables
similar to how we would normally do
within our template literals now last
but not least say we wanted to actually
have a multi-line string and have that
printout let's go ahead and comment this
part out here and we'll create this
variable called example in the past how
we would have to do a multi-line string
we'll do hello world hello and then we
want world to be on the next we'd have
to escape the with the slash and then we
can go ahead and add world so and then
because of the way that console.log
works with it's not going to actually
showcase it here as you'll see it's
going to print it out on one line so
we'll have to do is we'll jump into our
index.html I'll create a little
paragraph tag and what we're gonna do is
we're just going to give it an ID equal
to example and then in our index I J us
instead of console.log again we're gonna
go ahead and just target that so that we
can actually see it being on multiple
lines on the page so we're going to
document good element by ID and then
we're gonna say example which is the ID
on the page or set this equal to our
example variable it's gonna save it
excuse me
dot inner text because we need we're
trying to set the text value of that and
then you'll see hello world on two lines
although this /n is really sort of
obnoxious so how can we go about and fix
that well let's go and use our variables
here with some string with our template
literals so we use the backticks you'll
notice on the first line here I'm gonna
put my name which would be word 1 and
then on the second line I'm just going
to go ahead and put word 2 on here and
us formatting our string like this will
also get billing is your own multiple
lines and if we obviously didn't want
that we could do it on one line as well
but it allows us a very easy way a very
clean way to have multi-line strings
one of my favorite additions to the
JavaScript programming language has been
destructuring
objects so see here we have this
personal information object with first
name last name city state zip code a
bunch of stuff now what we want to do is
or what be structuring objects gives us
the ability to is it gives us the
ability to essentially write shorthand
code as well as reassigned values what
what I mean by that let's go ahead and
create a conjurer where you'll see we
have this opening and closing curly
brace and what we want to do is we just
want to put first name one access first
name because personal information about
first name every time we want to use it
that's kind of a pain it's kind of a
long name we're gonna access last name
and anything and we could access every
property on here if you want and on this
side well you're gonna go ahead and just
set it equal to the personal information
constant now see what that's gonna give
us the ability to do here is and let's
go ahead and use some template literals
or string string and relation here and
it's gonna give us the ability to just
do something like this we're gonna do
first name and then last name and it's
gonna print it out like so and we don't
have to do personal information dot
first name every single time we want to
use it but we can actually do one step
farther a one step further than that is
say we wanted to actually reassign the
value here we just put : and put FN for
first name and colon Ln for last name
and we could replace this and put FN and
Ln they hit those values as well you'll
see we have first name and last name now
I I would say that if you are going to
rename something you know make sure that
when it comes to naming convention it
makes sense or if you're gonna do very
short names like this in this instance
make sure that you follow good naming
not only a good naming convention but
also make sure that the scope of it is
very short but this allows us in general
2d structure our objects so that we can
have access to these things and we'll
talk a little bit about how we can
destructor
arrays in the
video
restructuring to raises another great
feature that's been added javascript in
recent years it's very similar to how we
D D structured the objects earlier so we
have this name array and what we want is
to essentially create a a pointer
element to D structure our array so that
we can get the first name the middle
name the last name in this instance how
might we do that well we can go ahead
and wrap it
remember how we wrapped it with the
object we wrap it only get first name
like so and we console dot log first
name you'll see you'll say we'll get
Dylan right and then we can do multiple
values right it's and we do we'll say
middle name and we can pass the middle
name we'll just do a little plus here
and throw in middle name it's gonna not
look very nice but you'll see we get
Dylan coding god we're doing coding
without any space and we could do last
name as well that's not that's not it as
and then let's just go ahead and print
this out piece by piece so we can see
it's all working now you'll notice that
it's going index by index we don't have
to have all of them but we can and in
our instance we can actually reset the
value here so first name is actually
storing a reference to that zero index
so if we wanted to override the value in
in in this case we could let's say I got
a let's go last name I got let's say my
girlfriend took I took on her last name
or something like that and we just goes
hey and I'll now become my Clemens it's
not gonna happen but we'll pretend right
and now you'll see that last name
becomes Clemens so this is one way that
you can D structure an array
if you haven't noticed by now es6 has
put an emphasis on writing less code
while still being readable and
maintainable and object literals are no
different so what are object literals
well a little bit of the setup you see
we have this function here called a
dressmaker it takes in two properties
city and state let's define a new
variable and we'll just call this new
address and right now we're gonna set it
to an empty object and all we want to do
at the end here is we're in console dot
log new address if we had let's say
we'll have a property called new city
and we'll set the value here to city and
then we'll have a new state and we'll
set the value to state and then you'll
notice that we print print out you know
new city Austin new state Texas as we
would expect nothing new here however
object literals give us the ability to
if these keys are the same as the value
that they're passing it we don't
actually have to set it it's going to
make the assumption so in this case
let's say instead of new city the key
was city instead of new state the key
was state what's gonna happen here is
it's going to assign the value of city
to city and of state to state and we
don't actually have to write city is
equal to city and state is equal to
state as you might have done in the past
and you'll you'll see it'll work the
same but object literals give us the
ability to do that now one caveat to
that is if you are going to use object
literals just make sure it makes sense
don't try to change your object or
change your properties so much so that
it doesn't make sense but object
literals is an excellent way for us not
to have to write duplicate code that
doesn't help in explaining it but allows
us to write less code while still being
very descriptive
all right in this challenge we're going
to try and combine the template literal
the object literal and the object D
structuring how might we do this with
the setup that we have here you'll see
we have this a dressmaker function
taking in a city and state key in the
object we then have this new address
where we're applying the values that
we're passing in and on the end goal all
we wanted to do is console.log the new
city the new state and the country with
it and we're going to use struct
destructuring we're gonna use template
literals and we're gonna use object
literals all right I hope you took a
second to try and figure this out on
your own if not that's okay and if you
struggled that's fine we're gonna go
through it right now so what we're gonna
do here let's recreate a constant and
we're gonna de structure our object
we're gonna pass in the city we're gonna
pass in the state and we're gonna set
the reference to the address object that
we're passing in is it's gonna give us
the ability to no longer need to say
address city we could in theory say city
city but that wouldn't use the object
literal and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna get rid of the city we're
gonna do the same thing with state as
well or the assignment of city because
this is going to know to say hey for the
city key assign this city value then
we're gonna leave country alone and last
but not least we're just gonna console
dot log our new address using
interpolation or template literals and
we're gonna say you address a city space
or comma and it'll say new address out
of state and then finally a little one
more comma and they'll do a last one
here of new address a country save it
and we're a good go so you see Austin
Texas United States
the four of loop is a great addition to
the JavaScript language and let me show
a case a little bit of what it does so
we wanted to iterate over all these
values in the array and perhaps add it
to this total value and at the end here
all we wanted to do was console out
console.log the total of the incomes
we could use the for of loop and it's
good start off as a simple for loop and
then we can define Const you know we're
gonna take income of incomes in our case
we're not going to reset the value of
anything in our in our logic nested in
the for loop so that's why we're using
cons but if you're going to reset income
nest it in there and use it for some
calculation or something like that you
would use let so we're gonna take aunts
and then we're going to say total
there's me total plus equals to the
income we're passing and we're good
something like two hundred and four
thousand now let's check how we're you
know if you wanted a console dot log out
income you can see we're gonna get each
individual income bracket here to that
so we get sixty two thousand sixty seven
thousand six sixty five thousand so this
income here is saying each element in
incomes are our iterable in this case
it's in array we're able to do something
with it and so that's really what the
for loop for of loop does is it allows
us to iterate through an entire entire
interval so you may have been wondering
why still and keep saying iterable and
not array well because we can actually
use the for of loop with various
intervals
what is another example of a popular
interval let's start off by get rid of
our previous logic here because they're
no longer going to use total and we
change it comes to let's say full name
or I set this equal to a string so you
can actually iterate over each character
of the string like so and instead of
becomes the path in full name instead of
income here we want to make
since we'll just call it chart and
passing chart and we'll save it and
you'll see here that as we print out our
logic we get DUI lan and then so on and
so forth and we can actually iterate
over strings as well so anything that is
an iterable we have the ability to go
through so that's mapsets typed arrays
and we're not gonna dive into this in
this course perhaps later on we may do
an advanced course where we break out
all the craziness that you can do in
JavaScript and some of the newer newer
types but here you can see that anything
that's an interval we can go through
with the for of loop
in this challenge we're gonna post a
question of what do you think would
happen if we gave each one of these
incomes a bump of $5,000 and change this
Const to a let and added $5,000 to the
income would it change it would it not
why might that be alright so hopefully
you took a second to figure out what
this might be and just sort of think
about it and let's see what happens when
we say look let me excuse me like take
income and set it you know equal to
itself and add $5,000 so I've got a
bonus what are we gonna get from income
don't notice none of our values change
well really you know the reason for this
is it's not designed to do that you
can't if you for some reason we're going
to add a value to this you don't want to
create a new variable you could do that
and then store it elsewhere but in this
instance when we're using the lead and
we're trying to reset the value of the
forever loop that's not what it's
designed for its just designed to
iterate over iterables not actually used
to set up new values or update the
values of iterable objects
so what is the spread operator this is
another great addition to JavaScript and
one I use almost on a daily basis at
work so the spread operator you'll see
here in our in our setup is we have an
array of values and then we're just
printing out the values nothing special
here let's go ahead and create this
example - and this is gonna be an array
and then we're gonna say dot dot dot
example one what is that doing it's
essentially unwrapping the values of
example 1 into example 2 and you'll see
here only console.log get out all the
new values are being added to example 2
and it's also not passing it by
reference so is it instantiating a new
array in this instance and so if we were
to take example 2 dot push a push I'll
just push a boolean does that be a
number and then we want to check hey did
this actually pass this to example 1 if
it was by value no it didn't so because
we don't have that on example 1 there
now the spread operator can be used with
objects as well unfortunately we're not
going to be able to at this time
showcase I can show that an example of
it but we won't be able to actually see
it in practice the spread operator when
it comes to objects is a very new
feature and something that the Babel
setting says for any on Suba don't
currently compile because they're
probably a little bit more strict as
they should be but an example of what
might happen here is let's say we have
example 1 this is equal to an object the
first name so Dylan and then we said let
example 2 equal to an object and then
within here we might do dot dot dot
example 1 and what would happen here if
we were to and we're gonna comment this
out because this isn't going to run what
would happen here is that we would have
our example two essentially it would
unwrap the keys and the values that are
in example 1 and we get this object with
first name
and what first name of Dylan now there's
a bunch of different reasons that you
might do this I do it in my constructors
when it comes to typescript where
sometimes I'll have a default value for
a first name encase first name doesn't
come from the back end so I might have
something like first name is going to be
equal to not applicable and that way
when I'm writing my code is if
something's not passed from the back end
but I need to have a value another great
example is an empty array because that
will break our code if we're iterating
over something I'll assign an empty
array unless something comes fulfilling
that in the back end so it's just one
way of how you might use the spread
operator when it comes to objects once
it's a little bit more widely supported
the rest operator although not as widely
used as a spread operator is somewhat
similar and just as valuable so what is
the rest operator it gives us the
ability to get the arguments out of our
function and it's used in a case in
which we don't know how many inputs are
going to be used so in our example here
we have a function add with a parameter
called nums and all we want to really do
at the end of the day is console dot log
gums let's go ahead and just add a
function call real quick and so we'll
take add well pass in five or four and
cool it prints out for what if we wanted
this to take in as many numbers as
possible what's gonna happen right now
is our code is not gonna do what we
wanted to do we wanted it to print out
all of nums and in the past what we
might have to do to get those arguments
is there's an arguments object for
variables and you can see here it's
actually going to say look this is on
the zero index of our add function if
you want to think of it that way so your
zero input then the one input and then
we can get the values that way and we do
something with that now it's not an
array it's not iterable and typically
that's what you're gonna want to use so
in theory arguments have sort of been
deprecated unofficially with the rest
operator and what this is gonna allow us
to do is in our input here on the num so
you'll see we have the three dots that's
why I kind of say it's related to the
spread operator and now when we access
nums you'll see that we're gonna get an
array of the input values here so when
you're gonna write a function and you
don't know how many values are gonna be
inputted you just know it's going to be
some sort of value and you don't
necessarily want to just pass an array
for for various reasons you may want to
consider using the rest operator it's
extremely powerful I use it whenever I
need to I don't use it as much as the
spread operator but I find it much more
intuitive than having to convert the
arguments to an array and get the values
that way so the rest operators a great
addition to es6
we're going to recycle a little bit of
our code from the rest
operator section so just a reminder here
we have our function ad that's taking in
a numerous amount of values and using
the rest operator we're gonna get an
array of these values arrow functions
are a great way to eliminate some of the
really unnecessary boilerplate of
callback functions and that it comes
with a lot of functionality as well as
some gotchas that if you don't know
exists but let's start off by creating
this total and we're gonna we're going
to essentially call the reduce array
method using arrow functions to return
these values and then just below it
we're gonna console dot log out total
now this is a reminder nomes here is an
array so we can't we have access to all
the things that would come in so i've
reduced will just you x and y and you'll
notice here that I've already by pure
instinct typed this out I wanted to show
an instance of what we might do in the
past without arrow function so you'll
see function and then we'll define this
with the brackets and then let's say
return x plus y and then semicolon
semicolon go ahead and save and you'll
see we end up with 36 as it adds all the
numbers together so this callback
function we can replace using arrow
functions and the only downside to that
is that it doesn't have its own instance
of this which is may or may not hurt may
or may hurt you and your code so if you
come across that really just be aware
that that is part of the trade off for
what we're doing here so let's go
eliminate this function and so we can
eliminate this code and you're saying
well why are we getting this Eric well
when we eliminate function we have to
assign this arrow function hence the
name you'll see it still works but we
can actually eliminate even more code at
this point where if we're doing a simple
one-line return in our arrow function
such as just adding these values
together we can eliminate this curly
brace here
and we can also eliminate this return
statement and we can eliminate this
semicolon now what you get is a very
clean arrow function that will return
the values that we're looking for and we
have we've eliminated maybe 20
characters of code and a lot of spacing
for something that we really didn't need
to get going so our functions are very
powerful and they're also just very
condensing condense and eliminate a lot
of the the useless boilerplate when it
comes to callback functions
default parameters for JavaScript is
another new concept but it's been around
in other programming languages for quite
some time and it provides us a lot of
value that's going to stop a lot of
forced-air checking a force error
prevention and let's take a look at our
code here where we have an ADD function
takes in an array presumably it's called
a number a and you'll see here in our ad
we're not calling it which right now
we're not using them all right but let's
say we were we wanted for each iteration
of number a we're in a for each on it
take an element you'll know something
we're going to be go ahead and use the
arrow functions and we want to say total
plus equals to that element what's going
to happen here in our current iteration
is we're going to err right type air for
each fun to find we never passed in
Gnome array and that's what I'm going to
give us an issue because we don't have a
we don't have an array to iterate over
now what we can do instead is we can use
optional parameters to help prevent this
from airing our code out because
sometimes maybe someone calls it
sometimes maybe it doesn't matter
sometimes it's just going to be an empty
array or whatever the case may be but
now what happens is when number a isn't
passed in we are providing a empty array
saying hey if it doesn't exist so to an
empty array therefore our array methods
don't break and then in our case we just
get a total that returns zero because
there's nothing to iterate over and thus
nothing gets added to the total
so an plus equals there we go and thus
we have a solution in place to prevent
those undefined errors that it will be
so rampant especially when you get
incorrect data maybe from AP is or
back-end or even just your own logic or
user input
JavaScript's always been kind of a
strange language in the fact that we
don't always have a method that does
what you would expect a language to have
and so in the past when we wanted to
check if an array had a value we would
use index of so in our case we've
console dot log and we say number a dot
index of and index of course returns the
index of values in there and if it's an
index value like zero it's going to
return negative one because it doesn't
exist that's kind of wonky and so we got
introduced to a new method called
includes and includes rule return a
boolean value of true or false so you'll
see here when we throw in zero it's
going to return false and when we
include two here it's going to return
true because it's contained within the
array one thing to keep in mind for this
if you are trying to support internet
explorer for some unknown reason you may
run into issues this is not supported by
Internet Explorer but it is supported by
all major web browsers besides ie
we're gonna talk a little bit about
letting kant's but so in order to
understand why let exists and cons for
that matter exist you have to sort of
understand a variable hoisting in
JavaScript let's take a look at our
example code right here you'll see that
we have if false VAR example is equal to
5 console dot log example now what may
surprise you is that we're gonna get a
null value and not a like this is
completely an error why would you log
this value and that's because of what's
called variable hoisting when you when
it comes to Java scripts of var is it
hoist the variables and so what
JavaScript actually sees when this
renders is what's in our commented out
code here where of our example and it
wastes it to the to the root late' to
the essentially to the function scope
level and then it looks like Oh example
is equal to 5 and in console logs a so
it hoists your variable and this is
solved by using letting Const moving
forward so let's dive in a little bit
about letting constant so let
essentially is a stricter version of var
and which it uses block scope so in our
case right now we're going to know we're
not getting an error though when we try
a logout example however if we go ahead
and define let in our instance here
you're gonna see that we're gonna get a
undefined there because let the example
variable doesn't exist unless it's
within this nested block scope as you
might imagine because the way that it's
actually interpreting it is exactly how
it is printed which makes a lot of sense
so although function of F var is using
hoisting let does not and neither does
Const and moving forward you for the
most part should be always using let
when you're gonna have values that are
reassigned ball now let's dive in a
little bit about constant how that
differs from let Const as you might have
guessed stands for constant but it may
not work in the exact same way that you
would expect so let's go ahead and clean
up our code a little bit here
Const is denoted by the Const
and we'll just say example and we're
gonna set this equal to a print
of data type which would be a number a a
string or a boolean so we're excluding
objects and arrays now what you may see
console dialog as ever as you would
expect in our example we're gonna get
the value however we can't actually
reset the value example when we're
dealing with the primitive types will
give us an air so let's set this to 10
doesn't matter if it's the same type
example when dealing with the primitive
types are read-only properties these are
things that have been set and you don't
plan on changing however where this may
get a little bit confusing is this it's
not necessarily the case when we're
dealing with arrays so in our case we
have an empty array we can actually
still in our console push to it and set
it you know push a value to 5 that's
fine however if we wanted to change the
value from an array to I don't know 3
we're gonna get a syntax error so that's
not that's not OK and that goes the same
for objects if we have an empty object
here and see empty object we can
actually assign properties to it as well
and this will work similar to how array
works
so although Const is sort of a constant
theory it's not exactly you can modify
objects in a race but you cannot
override the datatypes with those moving
forward any and when it comes to
primitive values the numbers the strings
and the boolean so you can't change
those at all
import and export have been a great
addition to javascript it allows us to
follow the solid principles and do
dependency injection and and more
object-oriented programming ll
essentially allow our code to be more
modular in nature which it lends it to
be more egle easily organized which is a
great thing how do they work where they
do well let's take our example Jas file
that we have here and define in this
case we're gonna define just a variable
a Const variable and the reason that you
might do something like that is you may
have a data set that you're gonna use by
multiple parts of your application
and/or it may just be long it's cleaner
and you just want to in one spot it
really just doesn't matter but in our
case here we're going to find a Const
and this is just we're just gonna call
it data we're instead of equals to an
array we'll go ahead and throw in maybe
a 1 a 2 and a 3 really matter in this
case
so this export allows us to in this case
export data export data which we can
then import in another application you
can do classes you can do enums if
you're working in typescript and things
like that let's go ahead and show how we
can import it so we'll have this import
and then these two curly braces now
remember how we had data here that is
what we're gonna be importing within
these curly braces and in our example
here we don't have multiple things being
exported but if we did like a data - you
just throw comma and then you'd have
access to it we're gonna import data and
typically you want to space it out like
so and then you have to say from where
in our cases just from the example dot
bass file and now if we wanted to come
to that log data we could you'll see
here we actually get our one two three
we'd even create a reference to it like
beta equal let updated data equal data
really good push to it if we wanted to
as well and just treat it like any other
item that we wanted
updated there we go oops updated data
and there we go we go one two three and
five so this allows us to make our code
more module as well as be able to
organize in such a way it's very helpful
in something I use on a daily basis
javascript gives some more love for
Strings with the pad start and pad and
methods what this does is it gives us a
way to add values to the starter string
and add values to the end of the string
depending on how long the string is so
let's take the example here which is
myname which is five letters long what
we're gonna take in it what we're gonna
call on this is the pad start method and
this is going to allow us to put in an
integer in this case 10 and then we're
gonna follow up let's just throw in the
letter a and you'll see here when
console.log get out we get five A's and
gillan however let's say we space this
out like so when we put down Israel
we're just going to go in Israel there's
no there's no room left to add values on
to our string and and the vice-versa if
we wanted a to do with end start it's
gonna work in a similar fashion we're
just gonna add it on to the end and
gives me pad end I don't know I said pad
sir pad and you'll see okay there's no
values here and if we remove Israel
we'll have five values left then we'll
add Dylan a to the end of the string a
little bit of fun I haven't found a use
case where I would use pad starter
pattern but it's definitely worth
mentioning probably help you in some of
those algorithm sites where you're
practicing a little bit as well
so one thing you may not have noticed is
that are known because I didn't mention
it yet is that you can actually pass in
just a number here the second parameter
that we've been passed you know if the
string is optional so let's take a look
at my shameless plug right here
youtube.com slash cart or else 360
string which is very long string and a
very great YouTube channel but besides
that you'll see that we have a pad start
to 100 and a pad into 1 what do you
think is gonna happen to our string when
we do that did you come up with some
guesses if so and you guess that it add
an empty string you would have been
right for our 101 right here and you'll
see now it's gonna print it out we get
that empty string but it's actually
gonna print out if we called out a
length on it you'll see the length of
it's a hundred there's like 80 empty
characters on here just the editor here
is too smart to know not to print all 80
of those what about Pat in well in our
case it's just gonna ignore it right
because our string is clearly longer
than one empty character and thus it
prints out appropriately
classes are a great addition to take
javascript to be in a more
object-oriented way and what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna find a class and
showcase some of the things that you can
do with classes how they work that it's
gonna be one of the long longer sections
of this course but stick with it it's a
really important concept so let's start
by jumping into our animal J's file and
define a class you do that with this
class keyboard in our example we're
gonna use an animal because I have three
cats and I love animals so we've defined
the class here doesn't do anything yet
but we need to build a instance of this
and to do that we have to set up
something called a constructor to our
constructor here essentially set some
values when we only created in our case
maybe an animal has a type and we'll
also say it has no will say legs every
animal should have legs and go from
there and we're gonna use the this
keyword and say look this dot type
meaning that this animal class has a
type is equal to the type that we're
passing in and vice versa this dot legs
is equal to the value that we're passing
then when we create our object so as a
constructor here is really just
assigning those values to our animal
class now I think this will make more
sense if we use it in a example so let's
go ahead and we take what we learned
with the export remember export class
animal so all we have to do is our
expert on here and now we'll jump into
here we'll go ahead and import animal
from slash animal dot Jas and to create
an instance of a class we go ahead and
just create a variable here and we'll
say let cat equal new animal now when we
go ahead and we're get air we go ahead
and console that log cat you'll see that
it's telling us I'm surprised it even
printed that but essentially what the
issue is here is
we need to now go and add some values so
maybe we have a type we'll say cat and
legs we'll say four and we have access
to the sound so if we say cat type are
we gonna get bring a cat right if we say
cat dot legs we're gonna we're gonna get
legs and so we have access to those
properties and they're being set via the
constructor here the constructor is
setting these values that we're passing
in for our animal class so we already
shown you that we can get values but we
can also change values relatively easily
without having to change anything all we
have to do say cat
dot and you'll notice how its parts
bringing it up right legs or or type the
legs and let's say heaven forbid our cat
lost a leg now they have three we can
then reset the value of that just as we
would with any other object we can also
define functions in our classes and
you'll see that we aren't going to use
the function keyword for this so let's
say we define a meow or a make noise
function because this is a generic
animal classes not necessarily for a cat
and we'll take in a property we'll just
call it sound and then we'll go ahead
and console.log sound and while we're at
it why don't we go and practice a little
bit of the default crams because we
covered that earlier and we'll say meow
we'll just make the assumption actually
just a loud loud noise there yeah and
that should work just fine so now when
we go to index IPS let me say cat dot
make noise it's gonna complement at we
passed in and of course we can we made
it that optional parameter so if we do
pass meowing will now get me out from
our function that we've defined in our
animal class static may be a new concept
for those of you who are not familiar
with classes and object-oriented
programming and what static allows us to
do is essentially
create a function in our class in our
animal classes and this is since where
we don't actually have to create an
instance of animal to use it this is
often what happens when you're creating
a large library or you're importing
someone's stuff and you don't have to
create a instance of that class so let's
create a static and let's say we just
wanted to say return all we wanted to do
is return ten it uh it really could do
whatever you want it to do and we'll say
return okay and that's the function and
in here all we want to do is return 10
not the most impressive function but if
we were to comment all this out now and
all we wanted to do was console dot log
animal and then say return 10 you'll
notice that it's going to work just fine
excuse me it's a function call so we
have to use that you'll see we actually
get the number 10 and we never had to
instantiate the the class to use it so
these are really functions that you need
that you want to write that you don't
need an instance or anything to to
unique about it and that is just going
to take in some properties perhaps and
return some data or runs another great
option when it comes to classes is the
ability the ability to create a get
method so it is a good method a get
method is really a property you want to
create that only to return some value so
it's going to come fill out our static
or get rid of our static method here and
comment this back in and we'll go ahead
and just delete this don't no need to do
that we all know that works at this
point and we're gonna jump into our
animal GIS file and we're gonna create a
git and you'll see you'll notice we get
a keyword in front of our functional and
in here all we're gonna basically do is
return a string that says the type and
the legs now so maybe we'll we'll just
call this metadata and we're gonna
return with the backticks
say this uh this dot type now let's
let's make this look a little nice type
: space and then we'll say you know
maybe comma legs this dot legs and so
this get this getter here will allow us
to treat this as a property on our
object so when we jump back into index
dot is sort of printing out legs here if
we created it we can now get the
metadata on it and you'll notice that
it'll print out so that's another thing
that you can do it also gives us the
ability to maybe say call functions in
their height a little bit of our class
from that from the user if we want to
but this is a another great option when
it comes to working with classes now as
you continue to dive into classes and
the object-oriented programming approach
what will happen is you'll sometimes
have classes that will share properties
or be very similar right so in our
instance here we created this animal
class to replicate a cat but let's say
we had a dog and we had a cat and we had
a mouse and all these sort of things
there there may be a cat class or maybe
a DA class there may be a you know a
mouse class and but we wanted to inherit
some of this animal class and not have
to rewrite all of our logic well we
could do that by defining a new class
and we're gonna do it in the same file
here but typically probably have a
different folder and then just import
this animal class so we want to do if we
want to export a class and that's kind
of the case it's gonna be cat that
extends the animal class that's going to
allow us to inherit some properties from
that as well as overwrite the ones that
we want right and the one that uh you
know so we're gonna inherit this
constructor we're not gonna have our own
constructor but if we did we would we
could do that but we'd have to put some
keywords I'm going to show you this but
we're not going to use it right now
so let's say we wanted to have a
constructor in our cat class here like
so
and we're gonna have it also taken the
same parameters which was typin legs but
we also wanted to have a parameter tail
here and well maybe just make it a
boolean perhaps a cat got its tail
around over no longer has a tail so it's
a true or false but when we use this
constructor when it's being extended out
from a parent class in this case animal
we're gonna need to use the super
keyword let it know that hey pass in ass
in the values that work that we have
here which in this case is type and legs
and then we would also go about it the
same way here where we say this dot tail
it's equal to tail now we're not gonna
do that in this instance but I want to
bring that up that you may run into some
issues as well as you can use super to
call some functions from the parent
class but I just wanted to mention this
let's go ahead and keep moving forward
and see how we can override a method in
this case we're gonna override this make
noise method and we're just gonna make
noise and let's just still have it sound
and we'll set default equal to meow
there's this cat right I want to you
know and all its gonna do is console dot
log with sound and so what's gonna
happen here is these are both named the
same and they have the same amount of
arguments and because cat extends animal
we can overwrite this function in our
cat class to make it more unique and
more specific to what we're doing while
still have access to these other methods
so let's jump back into the index J s
and import our cat class and instead of
cat or an animal excuse me we're an
import cat the first thing we're gonna
do here is we're just gonna say hey cat
dot and make noise we'll see that it
will do the meow and it's not going to
give the loud sound that's before
because we've overwritten that class
over in the parent class in our child
class cat one last thing I wanted
we didn't really showcase it but we now
even though we're using our cat class
we've actually inherited the properties
and the types and the methods from our
parent animal class so we can get that
metadata for instance and you'll see
here we're gonna get the type of cat
legs is four so as you're starting using
this object-oriented approach I would
suggest using that lightly a lot of
times people create very tightly coupled
parent and child classes and sometimes
they should just be separate classes but
in certain instances it does make sense
to extend your parent class out and here
is a good example of how we might do
that
a debatable nice feature I'm not too big
a fan of this but a new feature added in
es6 is trailing commas so in the past if
you had an a comma that didn't follow
anything you would get an error however
now if we were to do something like
define a function we'll just call it ad
and we were to have you know pram 1 and
then we had this comma it would be fine
yeah there wouldn't be any sort of logic
air that would work just fine and same
goes for objects right so let's say pram
one will say well we'll just print out a
Const Berryville and we have name one
set it did Dylan and then we went and
set this trailing comma here that would
work as well it was use me this example
equal to Dylan and then at the end here
all we did was just a little good see it
confidant log program one and just an
example constant a long example but
trailing comments are now something
we're not doing anything that's a little
just call it though that we don't have
issues with anymore so you're allowed to
have trailing commas I'm not super big
fan of this I think this is something we
got put into JavaScript maybe someone
can convince me but just to solve little
tiny hairs but here's something that's
there be aware of it
so this is gonna be a little bit of a
longer section we're gonna be talking
about promises a sink and a weight and
how they are all sort of related when
working with them in the front-end and
JavaScript let's start by talking about
what we have on our page here you'll see
I have this constant that is a URL
that's gonna link us to a top 100 of the
all-time active users on free code camp
comm which is a open source JavaScript
site it's an excellent place if you're I
believe they're actually gonna be
partnering up with scrim but on some
future stuff so it's a check them out if
you're interested in that what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna do an
asynchronous call we're gonna go and do
an ajax call and and we're gonna be
using fetch which returns a promise
we're gonna showcase how to handle that
and then later on we're gonna showcase a
little bit of async and a weight and how
we might use that alongside promises so
let's let's get going here you'll see we
have our function get top 100 campers
this is not like call of duty campers
these are the campers of free code camp
we're use the fetch method here which
what this is going to do we're it's
gonna take any URL it's is really gonna
go and get the data that we're looking
for but there's a little bit more we
have to do for that we have to call this
dog then on it and you'll see here we'd
say then is it's returning a promise of
type response that's what that means
and so fetch is returning a promise then
we're going to handle that response
object which we then set a when the
promise actually gets delivered you can
kind of think of like hey we promised to
send you some data with fetch and then
says okay when when you actually send me
the data I'll do something with it in
the meantime just keep running your code
that's sort of how a secret is items
work and how promises work in this case
and then says hey I'm gonna give you a
response just say r4 response and what
we're gonna need to do is first we're
going to need to turn that into JSON
otherwise we're not gonna know what to
do with that our computer is in Goa hair
our JavaScript doesn't know what to do
with it and so we have to convert that
promise into something that we can
use once we do that we can then take
that with that promise which is another
promise and we can which at this point
we can say JSON and we can do something
with that data what do we want to do
with it well let's just say we want to
console.log the first value of that JSON
this is going to return an array of a
lot of values and put a little semicolon
here and we'll just see that our
asynchronous call guy so you can see
here we get this object from our Ajax
call now while we're at it let's go
ahead and showcase how we might catch
this Ajax call and in case an air is
thrown and that's I might have already
given it away it's by catching it and so
you'll see here catch takes in a err
result in our case we're not going to
use it because it's going to look
identical to the hair's we would get in
our application so if for any reason our
server side fails on the fetch are
converting it to JSON we're gonna get
that air so let's say that we wanted to
just console dot log failed so that we
know that it's firing off and we're
gonna go ahead and change this put like
an empty space here MA and save it
you'll see here wearing at this failed
message and none of this is actually
going to run because it failed
immediately at the fetch standpoint
let's go back and fix that and you'll
notice now it's gonna go ahead and print
out our code let's move on so now that
we've done our Ajax caller asynchronous
call and we've resolved the promises and
everything's working let's show how we
might do this with less code using
asynchronous and a wait for an ajax call
now just keep in mind you don't have to
use async and weight or promises just
for something when it's hitting a server
that's the most common instance but
let's say you had a timer and it was
timing out four three four seconds and
you wanted to have something to delay it
you might use promises or async await
for that I just wanted to show you the
most common one which is server calls
and get calls specifically so let's go
and fetch that data except instead of
doing it with the promise it's we're
gonna do with the async in a way we're
gonna define a function
same name as before and get top 100
campers now the way that you tell it
that it's an asynchronous function so
I'll just do so that's async in front of
it now it now the JavaScript knows like
hey there may be some asynchronous items
going on in our function and it will
give us access to the await keyword how
we're gonna get that data bring in just
to find a concert and we don't have to
store it but I think it's a little bit
easier it's explains the logic a little
bit more and we're gonna say this is
going to be equal to and we're gonna do
our first asynchronous call here which
is follow follow the logic is fetching
the data so we're gonna fetch on that
API URL now that we've done that and
what that await is saying is please wait
until this fetch completes whether it's
successful whether it's not please just
wait until it completes the next thing
that we want to do let me go ahead and
define a class here and call this JSON
this would be our second JSON which is 8
another asynchronous call and we're
gonna set this equal to a weight where
we're saying please a weight our
response being turned into JSON a
response dot JSON excuse me now that we
have that we have access to it and it's
saying this line won't run and it's not
gonna this line will not run until this
results that's what this a sink and a
weight is doing and finally at the end
here we can console dot log our JSON and
again we're hit that zero spot because
the data it's very large so when we save
look at this nice asynchronous call now
if this wasn't asynchronous and we
didn't have or wasn't an async in a way
what would happen here is our console
log wouldn't know what JSON 0 index is
because all the code would run
synchronously just one after another and
would not be resolved before we would
actually get this data
so this challenge is going to be a
little bit instructional as well as
really probably just by far the most
challenging one of the course so you'll
see here that we have a function called
resolve after three seconds and we
showcase how to use promises in are
having a promise being returned but we
actually showcase how to create one
you'll see here that we recreate we are
returning in this function a new promise
with the resolve eventually being the
data that we're going to pass that back
in our instance here we're going to set
a timeout for three seconds so promises
are typically used with asynchronous
calls or things that take time and in
our case that's what we're returning so
how might we solve this resolving that
promise to get that resolved set and how
might we solve this using a sink and a
wait really take a second to see if you
can solve this this is an important
concept all right hopefully you're able
to solve that if not don't sweat it this
is a fairly new concept for most people
javascript has been synchronous for some
time and now we're learning to work with
it asynchronously so how might we solve
this using the promise then mechanism
pretty straightforward if you remember
our last example we are going to call
our function resolve after three seconds
and then we're gonna call the promise
ethane dot then which takes in our
return data it's successful and then we
want to in our case just console dot log
that data which will fire off after
three seconds right 3,000 milliseconds
is one second so any day now there we
have resolved the other way that we can
go ahead and solve this if we're gonna
define a asynchronous function that uses
async and away let's go and define a
function remember when we're defining
async function so you use the async
keyword and we'll say get async data and
then at the end of course we're gonna
want to call this to call this function
to go get that data now in here all we
have to do is
a weight a weight our output a weight
our data using the a weight keyword so
we ignore this in a result that probably
be the most proper way of doing it conch
result and then a weight be resolved
after three seconds and in console dot
log that result which will happen in
exactly three seconds so our data here
it's all gonna flow properly it's all
gonna work properly and now we're we're
handling getting data from asynchronous
places or went from asynchronous
endpoints or in our case using promises
with timeouts and it's another way that
we can use this and important concept
moving forward when you're trying to
deal with with databases and getting
data receiving data so I hope you found
this helpful
so this have been a great addition to
JavaScript what they allow us to do is
create a unique list now how might we go
about creating a set you can start by
just creating a variable and you go
ahead and say Kant's I will just say
example set its equal to a new set and
then inside here we're going to throw in
an array and let's throw in some
duplicate value so reason for this is
the showcase the idea also the way that
Babel set up in scrim but right now it
doesn't fully work in terms of the way
that it compiles to the console.log so
instead of actually printing out the
example set to see it's just gonna say
set no way around that right now at this
time but the idea you'll see right here
we have two unique values in here and
that's all the set cares about the other
values they don't even exist so when we
want to see the size of it we can do it
with the dot size you can see there's
only two now let's say that we wanted to
add to our set that we have created here
we can do that with the add the add
method and we could throw in a new value
here five and this is gonna add three
and this add works the same way where if
the set already has the value I'm gonna
add it it's just gonna basically ignore
it now we can chain these as well if we
wanted to go ahead and throw seventeen
in there you'll see our set size
continues to increase you can also
remove values from set using delete one
thing to keep in mind is a cool function
of sets and my opinion anyhow is that
when you delete it but actually return
the boolean of true or false whether it
was successful so let's say we delete
five and we're gonna console dot log
this out what we're gonna get is true
because the five exists in there and
you'll see right here so then it of
course removes it from our element so
that's another side effect of the delete
method we can also check if a value even
exists in our set using the has property
so we still have five in this point
you wanna say hey does this set have
five and say it does it's true right and
exercise is four and then last but not
least one more thing to mention is that
we can actually clear out our entire set
and reset it with clear and then you'll
see our count here it's going to be zero
the last thing I want to mention is that
asset is iterable so you can use things
like for each on it and four of and all
the great ways that you would normally
iterate through a interval
let's just take a second to pat
ourselves on the back for finishing this
course because it is a hard thing to do
so many people start courses out and
they never get to the end they start it
they forget about it they move on they
go back to playing Halo or doing
whatever they're doing it is a hard
thing to intellectually stimulate
yourself as well as follow through with
that so congratulations for you for
finishing the course and as a favour for
going through and making the content
would you do me a favor and share the
course for scrimm bus sake as well as my
own this is a great introduction course
I really enjoyed making it and I hope
that you enjoyed it as well and if you
did sharing it it goes miles and so
what's next for you well given what
we've equipped you with with now the
introduction JavaScript and now the
introduction to es6 plus you're ready to
pretty much write anything so you can
start practicing you there's a bunch of
wonderful tutorials on scrim go to
practice and algorithms there I'll build
some projects or start your own project
you have the skills and have been you
know introduced to a ton of the core
concepts that you should be ready to
start building so they in JavaScript so
get out there start playing around and
enjoy yourself